i'm now going to do a bunch more
examples using the chain rule so let's
let's see once again if i had
f of x
is equal to
let's say actually i don't like what i'm
this tool that i'm using now let's say i
want to use this f of x is equal to
let's say
x to the third
plus
2 x squared
minus let's say minus x to the negative
2 we haven't put any negative exponents
in yet but i think you'll see that the
same patterns apply
and all of that to let's say the minus
7.
we want to figure out what f
prime of x or the derivative of f of x
is so this might seem very complicated
and daunting to you and obviously to
take this entire polynomial to the
negative seventh power would take you
forever but using the chain rule we can
do it quite quickly so the first thing
we want to do is we want to take the
derivative of the inner function i guess
we could call it we want to take the
derivative of this and what's the
derivative of x to the third plus 2x
squared minus x to the negative 2. well
we know how to do that that was the
first kind of type of derivatives we
learned how to do it's
3x squared
3x squared and then 2 times 2 plus
4x to the first or just 4x and then here
with the negative derivative we do the
exact a negative exponent we do the
exact same thing we say negative 2 times
the negative 1 right there's a 1 here
we don't write it down so negative 2
times negative 1 is plus 2
x to the and then we decrease the
exponent by one so it's x to the
negative three
right so we figured out what the
derivative of the inside is and then we
just multiply that
that whole thing
times the derivative of kind of the
entire expression so then that'll be we
take the minus seven
let me do a different color so this
is the entire thing
so then we take minus seven so it's
times
minus seven
this whole expression i'm going to run
out of space
x to the third plus two x squared minus
x to the minus 2
that's minus x to the minus 2.
and all that we just decrease this
exponent by 1 to the minus 8.
so let me write it all down a little bit
neater now so we get
f prime of x or the derivative of f of x
is equal to
three
x squared plus four x
plus two x to the minus three third
power
i don't know why i did that that's minus
three
times
minus seven
x to the third
plus
two x
minus x to the minus 2
all of that to the negative 8 power and
we could simplify it a little bit maybe
we could just multiply this minus 7
times we could distribute it across this
expression so we'd say
that equals minus seven so that equals
minus
21 x squared minus 28
x
minus 14
x to the negative 3
all of that
times x to the third
plus 2
x squared minus x to the minus 2
to the minus 8.
so there we did it we we took this what
i would say is a very complicated
function and using the chain rule and
just some of the basic rules we had
introduced a couple of presentations ago
we were able to find the derivative of
it and now we if we wanted to for
whatever application we could find the
slope of this function at any point
x by just substituting that point
into this
this uh
this equation and we'll get the slope at
that point so let me do a slightly
harder one to show you the chain rule
you can kind of go
arbitrarily deep in the chain rule and
once again i don't know
image let me see if i clear the image
image inverted oh that was pretty fast
look at that
okay so let's say i had
let me see if i can write it a little
bit thinner let's see if i had
f of x i don't know if you can see that
so i'm going to do a little fatter f of
x
is equal to
i want to make it a little bit more
complicated this time
x
to the minus 2
plus
five
x to the third
minus seven x
all of that to the fifth
and then this whole expression to the
third power so as you're saying sal
you're starting to go nuts this is this
is going to take us forever well i'll
show you using the chain rule it will
not take that long
so the way i think about it so let's see
f prime of x f prime of x
equals i start off kind of with the the
innermost function so let me let me see
if i can use colors to make it a little
bit simpler so let's take the derivative
of this innermost function first right i
mean let me actually give you the big
picture we want to find the derivative
of
of the innermost function and then a
little bit bigger and then a little bit
more big than that i know that's that's
not precise mathematical terms but
you'll get the point when i see this
show you this example so first we'll do
this inner inner function this inner
expression and the derivative that's
pretty easy right it's 15
x squared minus 7 right that was pretty
straightforward
and now we're going to want to multiply
that
times
this entire derivative here so let me
let me circle that in a different so
then we want to do this
we're going to multiply that times this
entire derivative well that's just
times
5 and we just pretend like this is just
like
this pretend like this was just an x
here right because the derivative of x
to the fifth is 5x to the fourth right
but instead of an x we have this whole
expression 5x to the third minus 7x
we'll write that
five x to the third minus seven x and
now the exponent here goes down by one
so it's five times five x to the third
minus seven x all of that to the fourth
power so we figured out the derivative
of this so far and then we want to
figure out the derivative of this so
we'll add it right because we're trying
to figure out the derivative of this
entire expression so this is an easy one
let me draw that in a different color
so then we want the derivative of this
so that's negative 2 times 3 so that's
negative 6
x to the minus 3. so what have we done
so far we've so far figured out the
derivative
of
this entire expression
right the derivative of that entire
expression using the chain rule
is this
and now we're almost done we just have
to multiply that so i'm going to just
i've run out of space on that line but
let's just assume that the line
continues so that's times
and now we just take the derivative of
kind of this whole big thing
and now it's going to be the derivative
of of i'm going to use this brown color
so it's a whole big expression to the
third power right so that becomes times
three
times the whole expression right that's
just three
times now i'm gonna write the whole
thing three x to the minus two
plus
5 x to the third minus 7 x
that to the fifth
and then you decrement this by 1 to the
second power
that was an ultra confusing example this
is probably the hardest chain rule
problem you'll you'll see in a lot of
the questions you'll have on your test
but you see it wasn't that difficult we
just kind of went to the smallest
possible function and actually the
smallest possible function would have
been one of these terms but we just
found the derivative of this
which was 15 x squared minus seven and
then we just use the principle that the
derivative of kind of a function is just
the derivative of each of its parts
so
well actually the derivative of
we figured out the derivative of this
inner piece which was 15 x squared minus
seven and then we multiply it times the
derivative of this slightly larger piece
which is five times this entire
expression to the fourth
then we added it to the derivative of
three x and minus two
and then that whole thing and actually i
should put a big parenthesis around here
that whole thing we multiply it times
the derivative of this larger expression
i think i might have confused you so i
apologize if i have and in the next
presentation i'm going to do a bunch
more of chain rule problems and at some
point it should start to make sense to
you i think it's just a matter of seeing
example after example after example i'll
see you into the next presentation and i
apologize if i confused you